hey youtubers is Charlie so this week we
got two episodes of legend of course so
this is gonna be my combined review of
both of them its episodes four and five
episode 4 was the conclusion of one
two-parter in Episode five was like the
beginning of another but I'll explain
how that all works just be the leaf just
be the leaf and we'll go with it
real quick clone new people if you're
just finding me for the first time I do
Legend of Korra videos every week be
sure to subscribe to get everything and
shout out to last week's giveaway winner
the real spider Mew I'll be messaging
you on your channel you basically win an
Amazon gift card all you have to do to
participate in the weekly giveaway is
just be a subscriber and leave a comment
on my review videos on us who the winner
is whenever I post my Q&A video tomorrow
so I'm gonna start with my top 10
moments from both episodes and then I'll
do my review careful for spoilers if you
haven't seen the episodes yet but here
we go I'll just wait just a second okay
ready here we go number 10 welcome to
xiaofu city of the metalbenders this is
an avatar first we've never seen a city
made completely out of metal before it's
like looking at a metal garden my
favorite part of it all was the dance
academy with the metal flower they were
using to practice with all the trailers
were a little bit misleading because I
actually thought that they were training
to fight like training in a military
fashion to metalbend it's kind of funny
because it's a nice mirror for the story
in episode 4 with the Dai Li airbending
army training and we're probably also
gonna see the northern air temple
airbending training too it's a really
cool juxtaposition of the craziness in
Ba Sing se and the serenity that's going
on right now in South ooh
couple of really important facts about
the city su Yin built it with the help
of her husband and Toph just visited it
I thought it was so cool when opal gave
that shout out to grandma Toph whenever
she called it the safest city in the
world she was probably just referring to
those metal rose petals covering the
buildings at night since they were so
huge I'm just gonna assume that it takes
several metalbenders each day to open
and close them it seems mostly like it's
a city of artists and reformed criminals
looking for a new way of life which kind
of explains why su Yin thought the idea
of the earth Kingdom still having a
queen was ridiculous who else is hoping
that we get a classic fire ferrets scene
with that metal bending game before they
leave the city
number 9 meet your new family members su
Yin and opal so there were actually a
lot of new characters in su Yin has five
children not just opal but opal and Tsui
are the big new characters all that
bolon shipping just makes it pretty
clear that she's gonna join team korra
at some point and help them this year
that character is voiced by Alyson
Stoner and suyun is voiced by anne heche
in case you didn't recognize them this
episode was just the first part of a
two-part episode so next week we're
gonna get a big beifong flashbacks we'll
find out what all the bad blood in the
family history is about Lynne kind of
came off like a in this episode
but we really don't know what her beef
is so don't be too quick to judge they
said it had been about 30 years so
whatever su Yin did that Lynne claims
broke their family apart I'm hoping they
show it I think that they're supposed to
show how Lynne got her scars they did
definitely show them off a lot whenever
Lynne was on screen in episode 5 but I
find it hard to believe that her just
getting scars would break their family
apart for 30 years so I don't know if
that's the only part of what their bad
blood is about since Tenzin's family
became a huge part of book 2 I'm
wondering if su Yin also follows team
core around this season
it sounds like they'll eventually
resolve their beifong family issues so
I'm expecting some similar team ups in
the finale just like we got with Aang
still drew in the book 2 finale really
though I think the most interesting part
of all this soo-eun stuff is that
neither one of them knew their fathers
if you didn't catch it there only half
sisters I'm betting that the Duke was at
least one of their fathers and the other
one was just a character we haven't met
yet I know all of you really wanted
Sokka to be Lin's father but think about
it this way that would make things
really awkward since Lynn and Tenzin
were lovers when they were children I
don't think we're meant to find out who
either one of those fathers are at least
until Toph comes back you know maybe
even in book 4 or it's also possible
that they could reveal that in the comic
and not even do it on the show number 8
team Korra Prison Break
lots of prison breaks going on the
episode both very cool I'm interested to
see what the consequences of Cora's
actions are or if they just drop that
plot the earth Queen did claimed that
taking the airbenders is an act of war
but unless she mobilizes against the
northern air temple or against Republic
City or something like that it seems
like they're just gonna drop it we did
get to see Jinora use her new ability it
seems like a cross between energy
bending and entering the spirit world
like she's separating her consciousness
from her body but she's still able to
remain in the physical realm so if it's
not completely clear even though
conversions happen in both the spirit
portals are open the physical realm and
the spirit realm are still completely
two distinct areas so even though the
spirits are roaming free in the physical
realm you can still travel to the spirit
realm is still a separate place number
seven team Zaheer breaks out
sparky-sparky boom girl as cool as this
was all I could think about were the
similarities between team Zaheer and
team Korra they actually seem like
pretty normal people they're just trying
to get their friend out of jail and they
actually had senses of humor they made
jokes they even have his ships they even
had like their own version of McCory
this is in contrast to previous villains
like Amon and unlock that were pretty
much straight-up black hat wearing
villains you know there was no doubt
with those characters that they were bad
the way they're developing team Zaheer
makes me wonder if they're going to end
up helping Korra do something really
important like bring about a new age
that's good but only it seems bad
because Tenzin Sokka and Zuko never
found out what their plan was I'm really
hoping that they reveal what that is in
the next couple of episodes but on to
number six the Dai Li training camp did
anybody else think of Karate Kid
whenever the Dai Li was yelling no mercy
all I could think about was the no mercy
in our dojo line is so funny so what's
actually really surprised me about all
these new airbenders is is how good some
of them are despite having just started
airbending so here is the most extreme
example like he seems like he's been
bending for years and Kai even seemed
really sophisticated with his technique
especially when he was saving Jinora
from the Dai Li I don't necessarily
expect them to explain why they're so
good so fast I think we're just meant to
take away that they're naturally gifted
or prodigies like anger Azula but number
5 Varrick returns now he's supposed to
be building a maglev high-speed rail
system without Zhu Li apparently who
knows where she is I love that they kind
of buried the lede and made it seem like
he was doing weird spiritual things with
magnets so even though Varrick is a
qualified douchebag he actually does
conduct real business so high speed rail
seems like in keeping with the series
take on modernization it's like we go
from feudalism in Aang's time to cars
and mechs in Korra's time so high-speed
rail is just the next step next thing
you know we'll see microchips and
energy-based weapons and number four all
of the new ships
whenever Mike and Brian said that the
teenage romance stuff wouldn't be as big
of a thing this season I didn't really
know what that meant because of Jakaya
and bhopal now I'm thinking that you
know yes there's gonna be romance the
story's just not gonna feature it on
screen as much so for instance whenever
Korra interrupted Bolin and opal I think
that's just the writers telling us that
you know yes
this is gonna be a thing they're gonna
be a couple but it's mostly gonna take
place off screen but they're not gonna
subject us to it too much and number
three kya versus here I think it's
totally awesome that kya doesn't have to
just be a healer this season whenever we
met her last year she seemed like more
of a hippie I'm just glad that we get to
see more female characters on the show
that aren't just mothers or healers you
can totally be a badass waterbender or a
crankypants metalbender more to that
even on team Zaheer it's the female
members that have thus far seem like the
most proficient benders I'm talking
about the armless waterbender ming-hua
and pi li the sparky-sparky boom girl
but number two Lynne in Tencent explain
team Zaheer the biggest WTF from all
this is they still have no idea why is
it here wanted to kidnap the avatar
clearly it's going to be the red herring
this season but harmonic convergence
already happened and Korra has already
been separated from raava who was then
killed then resurrected to reform the
avatar
so what could say here possibly want to
do that would top that and they don't
seem evil so I don't think they're
trying to kill Korra I'm wondering if
they're going to hold off explaining
their plan until the last couple of
episodes it didn't really become clear
what the unlock vaatu plan was till
after the avatar Wan episodes last year
and my number one WTF moment wasn't any
of the big battles of the funny moments
it was actually so here reading guru
laghima's pendant the one that belonged
to Tenzin here's what the poem said on
it let go of your earthly attachments
enter the void and become the wind so
every time we get a Zaheer scene we
actually learned a little bit more about
him because he kind of does that evil
guy monologue thing even though he's
technically not evil I interpreted the
poem in a couple ways you know one it's
the guiding principle of all airbenders
leaving behind earthly attachments and
pursuing a more spiritual life but that
second part about entering the void got
me thinking I'm wondering if Zaheer
wants to use Korra to master death
that's just my first take on it after
seeing the episode the first
so I might change my opinion as I think
more about it but let me know what do
you think that Sahir's poem meant in
that context whatever he was saying it
out loud I didn't mention it before but
it key teaching the airbenders how to
use the airbending gates was so funny as
creepy as I hear was I love that he
bowed to Ikki as his master after he
used them I do secretly wonder though if
everything he says has some sort of
double meaning when he called a key
master he said that each student is only
as good as their master so does that
mean that he studied under an airbending
master at some point or maybe a guru it
seems like he knows more about bending
history and bending lore that unlock did
so let me know what your favorite moment
was I'm gonna say team Zaheer was
totally awesome and I cannot wait to see
more of their scenes Ikki being the leaf
was hilarious and I just love the metal
bending city it was so beautiful overall
this is probably my favorite episode so
far I did give it a solid a mostly for
character development in the way it
dealt with female relationships without
getting too caddied like you see in a
lot of children's shows Lin beifong is
so rich with pathos this season I cannot
wait to see some flashbacks the set up
they're doing first here's mystery plan
seems so big I have to believe that it
has something to do with conquering
death the other thing that I really
noticed about the episodes it's really
strong on Korra that you don't
necessarily think about another things
were the soundtrack the music the one
during the prison break in the old timey
music during the dinner scene were my
favorites they usually wait forever to
release soundtracks which is really
frustrating so I might have to extract
them from the broadcast or something
until they release them on iTunes so
next week's episode is basically the
second part of episode 5 and the only
thing that I don't like about core right
now is the way Nickelodeon is pairing
the episodes up there basically
mismatching episodes you know forget
doubling up if they're gonna do that I
can totally live with two episodes at a
time but at least pair the two partners
with the right story arcs so like I said
because I'm pairing episodes four and
five in this video I'm gonna do a Q&A
tomorrow be sure to subscribe to get it
I'll be sure to announce the giveaway
winners in that video normally I'd wait
till next week right now click here to
get that video
I'll add the annotation as soon as I
post it tomorrow and click here to get
my top ten Last Airbender characters on
Korra
thank you so much for watching I'll see
you guys tomorrow evacs
[Music]